you've been in the business a while and
you're at a level where i would think
you've met
pretty much everybody who
present company aside blew you away the
most who are you most excited to meet
oh gosh well i have to say of
all the people um you know i've worked
with
incredible people like will that i knew
as a friend beforehand but
jack nicholson has to be the
most satisfying celebrity
interaction for me because number one
growing up all of those legendary movies
you know like
nicholson has had an amazing run is it
true that john nicholson invited you to
a concert a youtube concert
yes so we're in detroit
and it was getting towards the end of
the shooting
and i had this great scene in the movie
where i betray his character on the
stand
on a side note when i betray his
character on the stand my mom
was watching the movie in a movie
theater and she
and when i when i turn on him on court
she goes not my
john and afterwards i was like mom
what did you say there and she's like i
said not you and i was like what do you
mean
she's like you wouldn't be a stool
pigeon i was like
mom it's a part it's not a role i was
telling the truth the character was
telling the truth these guys were
criminals like
i was telling like she's like no but you
wouldn't be a stool pigeon tell me you
wouldn't be a stool fish and i was like
wow okay i was hoping for a more ethical
take from my mom but
anyway um god rest her soul sorry mom
uh but yeah so we were shooting that
scene
and and i was feeling really good
because it was a great little dramatic
turn
i didn't have a ton to do in that movie
but it was a great little dramatic turn
and i was feeling really proud of myself
and danny devito who directed it was
really happy
and jack was saying stuff like hey he's
like he's like a young gene hackman and
i was like oh
[ __ ] like he just called me a young gene
hackman like um
so i was just feeling really good about
myself and i remember just like top of
the world i'm walking down the hallway
in this location where we're shooting
and i go into the bathroom
and i settle up to the urinal i'm just
thinking about like things and
and all of a sudden before i can even
start peeing jack comes in
to the bathroom and i was like oh [ __ ]
it's it's the man
and he not only does he come into the
bathroom he stands next to me
at the urinal next to me now
in any situation in that kind of you
know
two men alone in the restroom side by
side at the urinal i'm gonna get a shy
bladder you know
yeah it's just i you know i wish i was
one of those guys who could just
hit the fire hose no matter who's
standing around
but i'm not you know i just kind of get
like i psyched myself out and i try to
think about the sound of running water
or i don't know what i do but
the jack walks up and he he's the fire
hose guy
i can hear right away jack's peeing no
problem like
son of a [ __ ] i'm looking down and my
penis has become like a belly button you
know it's like
it's receded deep into my body
and i'm just trying to concentrate like
come on don't blow it just
relax he's gonna hear or maybe i'll just
wait it out
like and then he's peeing he's like
he goes you like you too
and i'll go yeah yeah i do jack
literally both of us with our hands on
our penises my micro penis and his
normal penis and uh and i go yeah i do
and he's like
you want to go see him i go yeah that
would be awesome he was like
you're in they're pals of mine and he
zips up his shorts
he washes his hand he's like talk to
chet he'll tell you what time we're
leaving and the concert was that night
and i was like
oh okay thank you jack and then ah after
he left i was able to relax and pee
and then he was the sweetest thing like
you know
i met downstairs in the lobby and i
thought like
i'm gonna go in the limousine with jack
to go see you too
like how can this be happening to me we
drive to the venue we pull into the back
of the loading zone it's like
the most preposterous way to enter a
concert i think i've ever
you know experienced like oh yeah of
course just pulling to the loading dock
backstage like
that's how you go see you two and we're
standing there backstage and then at
that point
jack tells his assistant and these other
people beat it you know go to your seats
like john john c stay with me
beat it scram it's me and john c he
talks like mo from the
stooges i do a terrible [ __ ] i'm sorry
but that's okay
um and uh and so i'm standing there
and then all of a sudden you see one two
three
four the four of them go up the stairs
to start the show
and the crowd just goes
it must have been 60 000 people in this
indoor arena
and and as this roar comes up and the
lights start to come up on the stage
jack turns to me and goes let's go
and he just starts walking out into the
crowd we don't have security
no one with us and it was like conan was
like
following macarthur onto the beach of
iwo jima you know like
it was like holy [ __ ] yeah yeah and we
head out up this aisle
and i realized the reason he's waited to
this moment is because the whole crowd
is looking at you too they're not
looking at jack nicholson walking up the
center aisle
of the stadium so we walk all the way
back i follow him and he goes
immediately to the sound booth
and we stand at the sound booth and i'll
never forget the way he danced it was
the
best like it was that it was that
concert i think was zoo
tv like when she moves in mysterious
ways
and can i stand yeah yeah yeah yeah this
is how nicholson is dancing
she moves here
we do we do